you see the narcissism of our present
culture
not just in congress not just in the
white house
you see it perhaps most clearly
in the amber heard trial
amber heard
was
out there you know she she just lost
this defamation case that johnny depp
brought against her she made all these
claims johnny depp beat her
he was abusive and then she was caught
on tape in many cases and certainly with
the testimony of witnesses having lied
and she lost that case now she's going
out and playing victim again even the
left-wing media
are calling her out on it in some cases
she was speaking to savannah guthrie on
the today show and guthrie just asked
this really basic question hold on
you're telling me that
all the evidence all the testimony
everybody who has some knowledge about
this
it's all just wrong they're all just
lying
even somebody who is
sure
i'm deserving
of
all this hate and vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
i absolutely can tell you that i didn't
even watch that much of the trial but
everything i saw suggests this was in
fact much more fair than many trials and
trials in court and trials in in the
press that we've seen in recent years a
lot of evidence was presented and
all of the evidence suggested that amber
heard was lying savannah guthrie pushes
her on this point she says wait hold on
you see you're saying that everything
that came out against you was just bs
but then there are other times there's
another tape where
you're taunting him and saying oh tell
the world johnny depp i a man the victim
of domestic violence 20 second clips or
the transcripts of them are not
representative of
even the two hours or the three hours
that those clips are excerpt from could
your side have just put the whole three
hours in then
i'm not a lawyer as i testified to i was
talking in those recordings as a person
an extreme amount of emotional
psychological and physical distress
he says doesn't never
hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is
what about the witnesses who said they
have seen you
instigate physical violence i've seen
firsthand how people will file rank
and support the person they depend on
did they all come in and lie in court
i am not here to call any of
these witnesses
any names i'm here to just kind of talk
about it from
what it felt like for me as the person
who
sat there there it is
there is the giveaway right there at the
end because she's just denied denied
deny the whole time that old italian
phrase in new york deny till you die
she's just keeping it up and then so
guthrie brings in this
this question of objective reality she's
saying okay well
if if what you say is true amber
then
everyone who testified against you
is
either extremely mistaken or more likely
lying
but amber her doesn't want to go that
far because it's absurd and so she says
no i'm not i'm not saying they're lying
i'm just telling you what it felt like
for me
see now it's no longer what it was what
it did what it what the reality is now
it's just this is what it felt like for
me
me me me me it's all about me and my
feelings she is so
insistent
upon her own will on her own desires and
which she wants
that she is
totally ignoring
truth and reality
she's just neglecting she doesn't really
care what it is and when and when forced
to confront that she says forget about
the truth for a second just talk about
me and my
feelings
when i talk about confused young women
there was a viral clip from one of the
pride parades around the country of some
poor young women who were dressed up in
all sorts of weird lgbt the baby blue
and the baby pink purple and all the
rainbow and the trans and this and that
and
an interviewer just came out and asked
them on the street hey what does this
mean for you who
why are you here today who are you
i'm gay
what age did you know that you were gay
um
i think at like 10 i knew that i
i think at 10 but i wasn't like
i wasn't clear on my gender
yeah i i think it was around like
10 as well when i started questioning if
i was bi and then since then it was kind
of like a slippery slope because i kept
i was like am i bi omni lesbian and then
i i kind of like
came to the point and then now recently
i've been like in my pan but then i like
i think
now i'm starting to realize that i'm
queer but yeah it was it started around
10 it wasn't like
fully
formed but i guess like that's when i
realized wait
that's a possibility
yeah i am genderqueer trans mask and
queer what's trans mask trans mask is
like people under the non-binary
umbrella at identifying like or
presenting mask
masculine yeah what about you
um
i'm trans and uh
on my sexuality is unlabeled
um
i use he him pronouns yeah and i used
today pronouns he him he they trans mask
i was gay then i realized i'm more pam
trans i don't know you know a little bit
none
by
transpan
what a wada bing bong
this video was put put up by savannah
hernandez and then her account got nuked
for apparently no reason but you can
still find it somewhere on the internet
apparently you know you can find it on
this show too we were lucky to get it
there it tells you so much about the
culture
and
do i feel bad for these young women i do
i genuinely feel bad for these young
women
do i do i think that the culture and the
society is leading people to these sorts
of disordered and destructive sexual
ideologies for sure
of course there's huge encouragement
everywhere you can't find a corporate
logo this month that doesn't have a
bunch of rainbow colors urging people of
every age all the way down to two years
old and three years old to pretend to be
the opposite sex and screw up their
bodies in their lives so yeah there's a
big part of that but there's a
this goes to the individual as well
it's an individual problem and it's not
just with that confused girl or the
confused girl next to her and it's not
just with the lgbt and the rainbows and
it's really a a totally pervasive
problem for all of us and the problem is
narcissism
do you think there is one second of the
day that those two young women aren't
thinking about themselves
the way that they talk well i was just i
was really focused on myself and in the
trans mask and then i realized no i'm a
little bit more of a pan today and then
i woke up and no i wasn't feeling like a
pan man i was feeling like a pot and a
plate you know i was a little bit more
of a trans by this that
you know there's a whole world out there
darling look at it you look up you can
see the birds in the sky you can see the
fish in the water you can you can read a
book that's great you can read a what
about a great novel how about you open
up jane austen that'll be really
interesting or go watch a documentary or
just i don't know observe other people
and stop thinking about yourself
because if you think about yourself all
the time you're going to drive yourself
insane which is what has happened
to to try to cure
narcissism egotism the the
self-absorption
to try to cure that you don't need to
think less of yourself
the whole point of pride month so they
say is that you shouldn't feel bad about
yourself you should feel really good
about yourself you shouldn't think of
yourself in a low way you should think
of yourself in this really high exalted
way but the the solution here is not to
think less of yourself the solution is
think of yourself less
just think of other things beyond you
think
a little bit less of your desires and
your appetites and your wants and start
thinking about objective reality and
maybe dare i suggest think about your
duties and your obligations and your
roles in your family and in your
community and in your country
think about that it will cure a lot of
those problems i'm glad you like that
clip now
ding ring wada wadda bing bong make sure
you hit that bell and
subscribe you will get all the
notifications then head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe there too to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you